how's it going bros my name is PewDiePie
oh my god we're playing ABS oh it's got
it's so [ __ ] good you got to keep
watching me try it try to keep up oh boy
come on buddy wake up come on we ain't
done yet oh dude you don't look too good
I mean you're fine you're you're you're
you're fine you're a robot as well we're
a robot as well we're a robot as well
but we have the Hartsdale oh my god we
have one of those inside oh my god so
this is so weird what the [ __ ] just
happened I did not expect this that is a
plot twist that is the hard twist man I
did not expect that I mean it wouldn't
make sense why we're breathing I don't
Sharky my man oh come on Sharky come on
buddy come on
come on no not Sharkey hey keep going
all events evil robots delete my phone
history sharks can't fam
they can't fat the saddest part of my
life right there
I'll avenge you shark II I'll find your
porn history of weird tentacle porn and
I why do I always have to ruin
everything with shitty sexual jokes I am
so sorry let's just keep going great
we're at the surface whoa okay all right
I can dig it
whoa all right nice nice
I mean I got shuck pretty good then
we're fine can we go up here we can what
what what the hell man
oh I'm walking so luckily you can tell I
belong and then on the ocean hey Sally
sorry I just randomly named that
salamander Sally because that's about as
original as my brain goes okay
very interesting
do not expect this to be honest
we're gonna do an epic died I believe
we're gonna hit big time
Wow yeah Pelkey f ed noise
what do we have over here that's the
meditation shirt
I don't know where we're going but
that's completely fine
I like it
oh it's a yachtie isn't that yet damn it
down what the [ __ ] are they called in
English whatever okay
dude this is making me so hungry for
fish
sorry vegans there's nothing like
swedish fish it's so delicious
I have not have a good fish meal since I
left Sweden the west coast of Sweden of
course
that fish had too much to drink hey it
happens to the best of us let's get the
other chain that to food chain hey
there's something here let's release it
they're all following me and I'm a lock
chorus oh I don't I don't know about you
guys but Adam I'm not into this
where is this chain man
I think I did it we could go up here
that was tricky man it was hidden that
[ __ ] was hidden dog I'm telling you that
wasn't easy that took me a while not
gonna lie here we go now we can press
this the door will open thank you very
much but I Bing badda boom bada BAM bada
bum bum
mad at me better better [ __ ] up okay
whoo
why did I take me so long I don't know
but you're lucky that there's editing
and this is not livestream because Jesus
Christ that was painful now let's skip
vide do down the stairs through a little
dive hip great that's exactly how I
wanted to do it and we're going and you
sir needs to [ __ ] do your [ __ ]
number two is finished we're going
through another door not a big deal okay
now we just got to play the swimming
game
yeah look at that speed oh they're all
following me it's so cool come with me
minion fishes no well [ __ ] up then I'm a
robot races for God what is that don't
like that thing I don't trust it it's
too weird what are you doing
I'm always scared when I swim that fish
is gonna come and bite my toes come on
don't tell me that you're not scared of
that eat [ __ ] either hey mr. turtle can
I ride you ah Thank You mr. Chadha
that's awfully kind of you
okay boov call cool with you this way
please
wow you're awfully slow slow oh god
you're not doing what I want okay [ __ ]
up then what do we have here is there
anything here yes there is
we're filling the fountain
the water of the water hey you never can
go up that makes perfect sense this is
how we we should apply get sucked up
hello
so beautiful my god and now we're here
okay let's keep going in this motor
temple huge as what a temple
okay now that's a little high now you
should probably try it out first ah
oh my god that was amazing
ooh I don't like this those dolphin
looking things I'll take I'll hitch a
ride with you it's ours boy we're
bringing dinosaurs in here get out of
here whoa
there is dinosaurs I'm pretty sure this
thing is extinct okay i'ma ride you baby
a lamas sour so they've been preserved
here that's amazing
okay we need to get that gate open these
guys are fast
there we go one
you could get out of the way please
fantastic
I'm starting to agree with IGN now like
10 out of 10 there's there's too much
water there is too much water all right
can I hit you right anyone yep you're
coming with me Sonny
Sonny Boy the Geo Sarris
hey you're not listening okay you did
that you did that
all right buddy I need you to focus come
on snap out of it
hey hey you're crazy Hey this thing is
crazy stop stop all right I don't like
you I'm going with you you're better you
don't eat everything
dude this guy's neck is insane imagine
him playing Pokemon go oh what was that
whoa sorry
the fountain is filled
very nice
the jaw is now open thank you
thank you very much you may proceed I
will all right
what the [ __ ] was that
fast go fast inches saris go fast there
it is yeah boy no he doesn't want to go
in okay that's fine that's fine that's
my quest that's my journey that's
absolutely fine
beautiful
oh one of those
what's this music a big front flip whoa
that's a cool temple
wait we built the sharks we built the
sharks everyone trying to understand
what they're saying I don't think we
build the Sharks hey don't nibble on
mine okay there seems to be a switch
here I'm a lot more into this story than
I was with journey I'm really curious
about the universe it's very interesting
whoa okay we got another huge answer
what a temple in front of us no this is
where we came from
yeah cool
we're getting up to the top that's a
Bjork fama nice and be our president
hey we're gonna swim in the canal my
favorite thing here we go
whoa the music changed Oh
yes give me the jet stream mr. Fisher
come on buddy Angwin Carribean let me
grab me I don't have to grab me either
front Blair come on buddy let me grab
you front Blair come on you're not
getting any speed up for them
after this I mean down what
hey this is where we started
fantastic
bellisima
whoa okay
Sharkey did not need to die for this
he will return
they live down here
okay
oh wow
oh my god oh wow look at that this gives
me shivers look at this
that's incredible how do they do this
look at that
amazing
they really created something special
that sounded so lame but I don't care
okay okay we need to open the game
epic jump
whoa yeah I bet a ballet huh
okay sorry I enjoy sorry I enjoyed the
game okay I'm sorry
what are you gonna do
okay let's get the other one
thank you
I can't wait to replay this game with
some random ass guy when I'm done with
it I'm serious okay what are you doing
man
you're not oh you are doing it okay just
a few that the music is so effective as
well they work as driver whatever
this game really proves that games can
be art I
I'm so blown away huh
okay I want it I want to stop this part
because I'm going to wait too long but I
want to keep playing and I'm worried
that I might be just at the edge of I'm
finishing it because this this might be
the last blob
and I ruined the whole atmosphere by
calling it a blob
yay Sharkey is back now next up Harambee
hey he's healing me
thanks Harambee I mean Sharkey you're
not so bad after all
hey man
whoa whoa whoa hey hey what what what oh
hell yeah this is some save Willy [ __ ]
oh holy oh oh yes yes [ __ ] you hey [ __ ]
you I keep missing them [ __ ] oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh my god this is amazing
oh hi mama oh I just said holy mama
great
thank you that's on the Internet Oh get
out okay
yeah let's race at sea level buddy
we ain't done for [ __ ] boy I'm shocked I
riding baby oh hell yeah do an epic jump
oh there's another one why do I have to
spin so fast so [ __ ] cold another one
Oh
incredible
jump
nailed it yeah nailed it
come on Sharky that's it yeah what's up
air hello the fish is following me it's
so cool I'm the king of the [ __ ] sea
baby yeah yeah that's right dude could I
jump there that baby
one more
okay we're going there
I suppose we could have jumped there
I thought it was the octopus a scam
man I wish I was a shark
I would just wreck [ __ ] [ __ ] you
I saved the octopus is great
here we go
try to keep it
Oh double rainbow oh my god i legit feel
like the double rainbow gang
I am the double rainbow look at this
yeah oh boy
we're going through it No thank you
Sharky I love you may I'll catch up with
you later dog
No oh yeah that's right chalky still
with me it's not a problem
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you and you you you
you you yep
come on boy
oh my god
oh my god we're going through we gonna
double up we made it to the surface
it's disappearing isn't it
we did it they did it again man they did
it again they created an absolutely
amazing [ __ ] game holy [ __ ] oh
they're cold Giants good I didn't
realize I hate giant squids I'm sorry
just go go buy this game right now
go play it you need to experience this
by yourself that was so amazing I loved
it that was so great oh my god
absolutely yeah you can even play here
this is so cool dude did it I know it's
short but I think that's okay it's cuz
every every second of it I enjoyed I
really did and he makes such a
difference I take this game over any
[ __ ] 100 hour game no but it's not
necessary either way I love this take on
unknown video games have a I love it
it's so I just I just like it I don't
know what to say I'm riding the shark
and I got to ride a great [ __ ] white
shark I'm sorry if I like that oh man
okay that was on way to lab and
neighbors I'm sorry I yelled
that was [ __ ] cool man
I was really cool I really really liked
it no quiz enjoyed as well thank you so
much for joining me on another journey
that was absolutely amazing please leave
it like me enjoyed and really appreciate
all the support when we do the series I
know they're very different from our the
daily type of content that we don't
normally do because that is more serious
and it's just me playing the game but I
know a lot of you appreciate it and it
makes it really fun for me to spice it
change it up a bit chin spices Adam it
also means a lot that you bros are
watching my videos I really appreciate
it
I love sharing gaming moments online
like this this is why I fell in love
with with YouTube Edgar I'm sorry I'm
almost done and it wouldn't be possible
if you weren't watching it and then I
want to say thank you for for being here
and please support games like this
because otherwise I wouldn't be able to
do what I'm doing in as well and that's
that's that's my final note so thank you
so much again and as always stay awesome
bros what oh god yeah [ __ ] yeah what do
I do now
yeah
Oh looks good